[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Dienstag Sport gibt es auch mit
Norbert Lehmann
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie
hat die Inflation den Höhepunkt
überschritten im Dezember steigen die
Preise etwas langsamer die Jahresbilanz
bleibt aber heftig
die Berliner Silvester Krawalle und
viele drängende Fragen wer sind die
Gewalttäter und was ist jetzt zu tun
und Schnee dringend gesucht zur Zeit
kommt das weiß in den Bergen vor allem
aus der Maschine
[Musik]
das Leben in Deutschland wird immer
teurer aber und das ist die gute
Nachricht von heute die Preise steigen
weniger schnell im Dezember lagen sie
nur noch 8,6% über dem Niveau des
Vorjahresmonats Grund zur Entspannung
gibt es trotzdem nicht sagen Experten
jahrelang mussten sich die Menschen in
Deutschland kaum Sorgen umsteigende
Preise machen die Inflation für einige
Fachleute fast schon zu niedrig aber
seit 2021 also schon vor dem Ukraine
Krieg steigen die Preise stark an im
vergangenen Jahr lag die Inflation
durchschnittlich bei
7,9% so hoch wie noch nie zuvor in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik Peter
treisen
nicht viel los Kurzarbeit bei der Firma
Vollmann in Minden hier produziert man
unter anderem Druckfarben und
Klebstreifen der Betrieb leidet massiv
unter den stark gestiegenen
Rohstoffpreisen Ammoniak als Beispiel
was in alle unsere Produkte geht hat
sich im Preis so weit gestiegen dass bei
uns die Rohstoffpreise insgesamt
gegenüber dem letzten Jahr sie
verdoppelt haben das können wir nicht
weitergeben das was passieren wird die
Abwanderung die Schließung die die
Industrialisierung mit weitergehen auf
die Beschäftigten in der Chemiebranche
wartet also trotz zuletzt gesunkener
Energiepreise und staatlicher
Hilfsmaßnahmen ein weiteres schwieriges
Jahr die Zukunft wie schon als
herausfordern egal ob es ein privaten
Umfeld ist mit den ganzen Preis
Geschichten die wir dann natürlich mit
stimmen müssen über alle mit stimmen
müssen aber wir haben hier auch schon
viele Krisen mit durchgemacht das kann
auch eine Chance für Unternehmen sein
immerhin mit den Energiepreisen ist nun
auch die Inflation deutlich gesunken
nach Werten von teilweise über 10% in
den vergangenen Monaten lag sie im
Dezember bei
8,6%. die Inflation ist im Dezember vor
allem deshalb gefallen weil der Staat
die Abschlagszahlung für Gas übernommen
hat und das haben die Statistiker
gewertet als Preisrückgang aber jenseits
der Energie dürfte die Inflation
hartnäckig hoch bleiben denn die
Lohnkosten steigen stärker und das
werden die Unternehmen weitergeben an
die Konsumenten ich gehe davon aus dass
wir auch im Durchschnitt eine
Inflationsrate dieses Jahr noch mal
sehen werden zwischen sechs und sieben
Prozent und ich denke es wird nur wenig
Arbeitnehmer geben die auch eine
Lohnerhöhung von sechs bis sieben
Prozent bekommen heißt der
durchschnittliche Arbeitnehmer wird
weiter noch real weniger Geld in der
Tasche haben trotz aller Probleme noch
arbeitet die Firma Vollmann profitabel
die 900 Mitarbeiter hoffen dass 2023
doch nicht so schlimm wird wie
befürchtet
der Arbeitsmarkt ist trotz Krise
erstaunlich robust 2022 waren im Schnitt
deutlich weniger Menschen arbeitslos als
im Jahr zuvor zwar ist im Dezember die
Zahl der Arbeitslosen ganz leicht
gestiegen allerdings wären es ohne
Schutzsuchende aus der Ukraine sogar
weniger als im vorherigen dezember in
Zahlen gesagt zwei Millionen
454.000 Menschen waren zuletzt ohne Job
die Arbeitslosenquote liegt bei 5,4
Prozent warum hält sich der Arbeitsmarkt
trotz Energie Inflation und Energiekrise
so gut Stefanie Barrett in Frankfurt ja
das ist ganz klar dem demografischen
Wandel geschuldet immer mehr Menschen
scheiden aus dem Erwerbsleben aus
deutlich weniger Berufseinsteiger Rücken
nach und es fehlen einfach alle Orten
Fachkräfte noch saugt der deutsche
Arbeitsmarkt jede Kraft auf der nur
bekommen kann und ist in diesen
Krisenzeiten ein echter stabilitäts-
Herausforderungen sind groß wenn
Unternehmen etwa weniger Aufträge
annehmen können weil ihnen schlicht die
Leute fehlen um sie abzuarbeiten oder
auch das Thema wettbewerbsfähige Energie
nicht gelöst wird dann hat das natürlich
auch Auswirkungen auf den Arbeitsmarkt
entweder verschlanken sich Unternehmen
machen unter Umständen sogar dicht oder
sie wandern ins Ausland ab und mit ihnen
dann auch die Arbeitsplätze umso
wichtiger also gezielt Fachkräfte im
Ausland anwerben und beschäftigte
hierzulande schneller fit machen für
neue Anforderungen danke für diese
Informationen aus Frankfurt Stefan
um steigende Preise und den gasmangel in
den Griff zu bekommen setzt Deutschland
ja auch auf verflüssigtes Erdgas aus dem
Ausland jetzt ist am neugebauten
Terminal in Wilhelmshaven erstmals ein
Tanker mit einer vollständigen Ladung
angekommen laut dem Betreiber uniper hat
die Maria energy genug Erdgas an Bord um
rund 50.000 Haushalte ein Jahr lang mit
Energie zu versorgen von Umweltschützern
kommt Kritik sie befürchten unter
anderem Schäden für das Wattenmeer
im Ukraine Krieg meldet Kiew weitere
Erfolge wieder sei es gelungen mit
artillerieangriffen auf russische
Stützpunkte dem Gegner empfindliche
Verluste zuzufügen diesmal habe man zwei
russische Stellungen im besetzten Süden
des Landes zerstört Belege dafür gibt es
noch keine im russischen Samara gab es
eine Trauerfeier für die ein neuer in
magiewka getöteten Soldaten dort waren
nach russischen Angaben 63 Rekruten dem
Artillerieangriff zum Opfer gefallen die
Ukraine spricht von rund 400 getöteten
Gegnern
fragen wir Tim Kröger in der Ukraine wie
sind diese Verluste für die russische
Armee einzuschätzen
also der ukrainische Generalstab hat
erst heute einen neuen Angriff bekannt
gegeben in der Region herson der sich
schon am Neujahrstag ereignet haben soll
dort ist die Rede von 500 Toten und
Verletzten auf Seiten der russischen
Truppen das ist natürlich eine sehr sehr
hohe Zahl die wir überhaupt nicht
verifizieren können aber wenn sich das
auch nur annähernd bestätigt dann wäre
das natürlich ein ganz schwerer Schlag
gegen die russischen Streitkräfte dann
wäre die da neuer Tag an dem sich ja
auch schon der Angriff in der Region
dann jetzt mit mindestens 63 Toten
ereignet hat einen sehr sehr
verlustreicher und wir hören jetzt schon
aus Russland dass die Kritik an der
russischen Kriegsführung bereits lauter
wird und natürlich liegt auch auf der
Hand dass solche Angriffe mit dutzenden
Verletzten und toten für die Moral der
russischen Truppen in dem besetzten
Gebieten der Ukraine fatales des die
Moral dort dadurch noch mal deutlich
sinken kannte danke für diese
Einschätzung
zurück nach Deutschland wer greift
Retter an und warum das sind die Fragen
die seit den Attacken in der
Silvesternacht viele umtreiben
festgenommen hat die Polizei nach
eigenen Angaben fast nur Männer ein Teil
mit Migrationshintergrund die meisten
sind inzwischen wieder auf freiem Fuß
die
Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung warnt davor die Täter
auf ihre vermutete Herkunft zu
reduzieren statt die sozialen Ursachen
zu bekämpfen Henriette de Maiziere
ein Löschfahrzeug der Berliner Feuerwehr
in der Silvesternacht eine Anwohnerin
filmt mit dem Handy Vollidioten
Feuerwehrmann Boris torwan kehrt zurück
an den Ort des Geschehens Trovan
erinnert sich es seien hunderte
Jugendliche gewesen die Steine und
Flaschen flogen in Unmengen auf uns und
Knaller Böller das waren junge
Heranwachsende größtenteils mit
Migrationshintergrund und das sage ich
selber obwohl ich ein
Migrationshintergrund haben meine ganze
Leben lang kämpfe ich schon gegen gegen
irgendwelche Vorurteile an aber was soll
ich denn da noch sagen fest steht es gab
145 festgenommene fast alle männlich und
jugendlich die Polizei gab inzwischen
deren Staatsangehörigkeiten bekannt 45
deutsche die anderen Festgenommenen
stammen aus 17 weiteren Nationen vor
allem Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
die das Gefühl haben Polizei ist ihr
Feind Polizei ist schwach Rechtsstaat
kann ihn nicht das ist dann das was dazu
führt dass diese Menschen bereit sind
sogar Gewalt anzuwenden um genau diese
Feindbilder zu attackieren Großstadt
Milieu junge Männer bereit Minister
Böller und Raketen als Waffen
einzusetzen Nervenkitzel Kräftemessen
von Halbstarken Spaß an der Gewalt was
treibt die Täter an es ist nicht
unbedingt ein Mod der dann irgendwie
alle Normen verliert sondern es ist eine
es ist eine Gruppendynamik in der dann
Gruppen auch bestätigt werden und der
dann die Gewalt erzeugt die
Zugehörigkeit sobald die Täter vor
Gericht stehen bereuen sie sagen sie ich
weiß selber gar nicht wie ich in die
Situation hinein kommen konnte der Müll
der Silvesternacht ist in desbeiner
beräumt was gerade erst beginnt ist die
gesellschaftliche und politische
Diskussion
für US-Präsident beiden wird das
Regieren ab heute deutlich schwieriger
bei den Zwischenwahlen im November haben
seine Demokraten zwar die Mehrheit im
Senat behalten aber im
Repräsentantenhaus ist es umgekehrt dort
haben jetzt die Republikaner die
Mehrheit und können vieles bestimmen
heute kommt der neue Kongress erstmals
zusammen aus Washington berichtet MRT
wissen
er strotzte heute morgen vor
Selbstbewusstsein Kevin McCarthy will
das dritthöchste Amt im staatsprecher
des Repräsentanten Hauses seine Sachen
hat er schon ins Büro bringen lassen von
dem aus bisher Nancy Lucy die Dinge
lenkte wer den Hammer hält bestimmt
nämlich über welche Themen in der
Parlamentskammer entschieden wird über
welche nicht der Kaffee droht mit
knallharter Politik und
Untersuchungsausschüssen gegen den
Präsidenten
die Ära der demokratischen
Einparteienherrschaft ist vorbei es gibt
wieder Kontrolle das amerikanische Volk
redet mit beim Regieren
aber die republikanische Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus ist knapp 222 zu 213
Stimmen und rund ein Dutzend
Republikaner wollen McCarthy heute nicht
wählen er ist ihnen nicht radikal genug
zum Wohl des Landes des Kongresses und
der Fraktion sollte er abtreten es geht
nicht um Ambition Stolz oder Eigennutzes
geht nicht um eine Person
um den Sumpf trocken zu legen können wir
nicht den größten Alligator beauftragen
es wäre historisch wenn wie zuletzt 1923
ein Sprecher nicht dem ersten Wahlgang
gewählt würde oder wie 1855 als es eine
Senior banks erst nach 133 Abstimmungen
schaffte bei einer turbulenten
Fraktionssitzung am Morgen forderten
mehrere Abgeordnete gute Posten für ihre
Stimmen mit Kaffee ist wütend
es könnte heute eine Schlacht werden
aber für die Fraktion und fürs Land das
ist für mich okay wirklich an die Arbeit
gehen kann der Kongress erst wenn das
sprecheramt besetzt ist verliert mcafe
hier wäre sein Zeichen für die
Unfähigkeit der Republikaner zu regieren
überraschend haben die abtrünnigen nun
sogar einen Gegenkandidaten nominiert es
wird eine polit-schlacht in Washington
[Applaus]
mit einem Requiem nimmt heute das
Erzbistum München und Freising Abschied
von Benedikt dem 16 der ehemalige Papst
ist am Silvestertag in Rom gestorben als
Kardinal Josef Ratzinger war er von 1977
bis
1982 Chef des Erzbistums überschattet
ist diese Zeit von Vorwürfen die
Kirchenleitung habe Missbrauchsfälle
nicht angemessen behandelt der jetzige
Amtsinhaber Kardinal Reinhard Marx
feierte den Gottesdienst im
Liebfrauendom
so wie hier in Riezlern in Österreich
sieht es derzeit in vielen Skigebieten
aus auf den Pisten gibt es Schnee
künstlichen aber drumherum ist es grün
dieses Skifahren auf Kunstschnee im
Grünen zeigt nicht nur die
Verletzlichkeit des Klimas auch die
Unfälle nehmen deutlich zu Britta
Hilpert hat mehr es mangelt nicht an
Gästen in Seefeld es mangelt am Schnee
in den tieferen Lagen heißt das
Skifahren auf weißem Band in den höheren
ist die dünne Schneedecke ab Mittag
abgefahren
vielerorts in Österreich das gleiche
Bild Schnee Inseln schneebänder unten
und auch oben muss beschneidt werden so
vieles geht mit dem Klimawandel wächst
eine neue Ski Generation heran
lohnt sich das denn eigentlich noch dass
die Kinder Skifahren lernen wer weiß wie
lange es das überhaupt noch gibt also
das ist alles ein bisschen ja
grenzwertig wenn du mein Sohn fragen
würde der würde sagen Hauptsache
Skifahren für unser eins selber ist es
natürlich schöner ja wenn man links und
rechts der Piste natürlich auch
entsprechende ja entsprechendes weiß
hätte es wäre auch sicherer denn auch in
den hohen Lagen federt nur wenig Schnee
das Geröll ab wenn Skifahrer von der
Piste geraten und die planierten glatten
kunstschneepisten haben einen Nachteil
sie verleiten zu Tempo um den
Jahreswechsel schossen mehrere Skifahrer
über die Pisten hinaus und sterben wir
haben wenig Schnee wir haben uns Pisten
und wenn man halt die Piste verlässt
oder die Piste wer Sturz verlässt dann
sein natürlich die Verletzungen höher
wie das einem guten winterlichen mit
sehr sehr viel Schnee seit Saison
beginnt starben in Österreich 13
Menschen am Berg so viele wie seit
Jahren nicht auch Herz-Kreislauf
Beschwerden sind oft Todesursache denn
nach den akademiewintern überschätzen
manche ihr Können und ihre Kondition
jetzt zum letzten Weg einer
Fußball-Legende mit einem Trauerzug hat
Brasilien Abschied von Pelé genommen der
sagt das dreifachen Weltmeisters wurde
auf dem Dach eines Feuerwehrautos zur
letzten Ruhestätte gebracht
zehntausende Menschen begleiteten die
Prozession die durch Santos zog die
Stadt von Pelés Lieblingsverein FC
Salzburg und vor einer Stunde ist der
Trauerzug am Friedhof angekommen dort
findet die Beisetzung im privaten Kreis
statt und dort vor Ort in Santos ist
Christoph röckerath wie war dieser
Abschied von Pelé
ja der offizielle Teil ist gerade eben
zu Ende gegangen als hier die das der
Sarg angekommen ist direkt auf diesem
Platz hier hinter uns und dann in diesen
sogenannten vertikalen Friedhof
verbracht worden ist das ist eine Art
Hochhaus mit mehreren Etagen und dort
findet in diesen Minuten im engsten
Familienkreis im 9 Stock die Beisetzung
von pelé-status der Abschluss eines ja
tatsächlich finde ich sehr emotionalen
Tages wir waren selber erstaunt wie die
Menschen hier doch noch mal reagiert
haben mein Eindruck war dass die
Menschen von Santos ihren Pelé nicht so
richtig ziehen lassen wollten die
Prozession durch die Stadt war begleitet
von immer mehr Menschen die geweint
haben die gebetet haben die auch
applaudiert haben oder einfach nur
diesen Feuerwehrwagen berühren wollten
auf dem sich der Sarg von Pele befand
hinzu kommt auch das bis zum Morgen
250000 Menschen im Stadion waren und
einzeln am offenen sagt von play noch
mal vorbei gelaufen sind und sich dort
verabschiedet haben also man kann sagen
dass die Brasilianer ihr großes Idol
würde und liebevoll heute zu Grabe
getragen haben danke schön für diese
Eindrücke aus dem brasilianischen Santos
danke Christopher
Filets letzter Weg nach einem äußerst
erfolgreichen Fußballer leben die
wichtigsten und spektakulärsten
Stationen seiner Karriere zeigen wir
noch mal online in Bildern und
Stichworten in unserer zettelf heute App
und jetzt gehen wir noch London zur
dartsweg aus der Traum eines
Weltmeisters aus dem Saarland ja schade
schade aber er ist und bleibt der erste
Deutsche der ist überhaupt bis ins
Halbfinale geschafft hat Shooting Star
Gabriel Clemens zunächst konnte er mit
dem Engländer Michael Smith noch
mithalten ja aber am Ende musste sich
der German giant dann doch deutlich mit
2 zu 6 setzen geschlagen geben trotz
Daumen drücken in der Heimat
zu Hause bei Familie Clemens die Eltern
von Gabriel am Tag danach emotional da
bin ich jetzt immer dabei sein
Auge wenn ich ihnen so hautnah sehe dann
habe ich immer tränende Augen die
Enttäuschung beim Sohn gestern groß
geschlagen von Michael Smith die
Anfangsphase ausgeglichen beide spielen
auf Augenhöhe gewinnen ihre Sätze bis
zum 6 dann SMS spektakulär über bullsei
zum Break er war vom scoring her brutal
stark und ich habe heute einfach gegen
den besseren Spieler verloren ein
bullyboy ist Mist mit dem ersten Match
statt ins Glück er im Finale Siemens
raus aber kein Verlierer denn in der
Heimat sind sie stolz auf Gaga im
Sportladen des datas heute viel los und
die Regale leer hoffen auf den dartsboom
in Deutschland
Licht und Schatten für die deutschen
Springer bei der Qualifikation für
Station 3 der Vierschanzentournee
Philipp Reimund in Innsbruck als Elfter
wieder mit einem guten Ergebnis
Hoffnungsträger Karl Geiger aber
überraschend gescheitert aus den Kampf
um das tourneepodest ist Karl Geiger nun
definitiv raus als 51 der Qualifikation
hat es Deutschlands derzeit
erfolgreichster Springer nicht in den
morgigen Wettbewerb geschafft nur 108
Meter für Geiger der 29-Jährige
fassungslos
dass der Sprung Zauber nix war aber ja
das ist für die Qualität nicht reicht
das ist eigentlich echt mies Philipp als
Elfter der beste von sechs
qualifizierten deutschen den
weitestensprung landete der gesamte
David Kubatzki aus Polen
Katharina Hennig hat bei der Tour de
schien Oberstdorf mit Rang 6 ihre gute
Form bestätigt über die zehn Kilometer
klassisch wurde die
langlauf-olympiasiegerin 6 damit reichte
es aber nicht zum erhofften ersten
deutschen Podestplatz in einem
Heimrennen seit 2013
siegerin wurde die Schwedin Frida
Karlsson
und in der Gesamtwertung hat sich ja
nicht sogar auf Platz 5 verbessert läuft
wir drücken weiter die Daumen Sturm und
Regen sind die Themen beim Wetter gleich
von ostentelli um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt Sie Marietta Slomka im heute
journal hier übernimmt morgen Jana
pareignis alles Gute Ihnen einen schönen
Abend noch und auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein neues Tief
zieht auf und das bringt ein
umfangreiches Regengebiet mit das
verlagert sich über Nacht weiter in den
Osten und auch tagsüber wandert es
weiter ostwärts und so regnet es
verbreitet und es ist ein Sturmtief ja
und in der Nacht gibt es vor allem
Richtung Nordsee kräftigen Wind aus
Südwest teils mit Sturmböen und
orkanartigen Böden es ist durchaus drin
oder auch in den höheren Lagen liegt der
Wind weiter zu das Regengebiet wandert
dabei allmählich nach Osten im Süden ist
es trocken ja und da merkt man nichts
davon Temperaturen dort ist -2 Grad 8
Grad plus Richtung Niederrhein morgen
morgen Vormittag liegt das Regengebiet
dann weiter im Osten von Westen er
einige Schauer und ganz im Süden starten
wir mit Sonnenschein in den Tag zum
Nachmittag verlagert sich das
Regengebiet weiter in den Osten der Wind
liegt weiter zu in den höheren Lagen
dann auch orkanartige Bönen dabei und
auch Richtung Nordsee orkanartige Böden
ja und auch Gewitter sind möglich und
ganz im Süden bleibt es noch trocken das
bei Temperaturen von 7 bis 13 Grad die
nächsten Tage kommen weitere
Regengebiete durchgezogen und es bleibt
weiterhin Milch damit ein schöner Abend